How tall is your mom?
I think she's like 40 kilograms or something.
From here to that brick.
What does your mom do around the house?
She cooks the dinner.
She does my hair.
She does my homework with me.
Because my dad doesn't do any cleaning, so my mom has to do all the cleaning.
She kinda does loads.
She really does loads.
She dresses me up for school every single day.
Why do you love your mom?
Because she's my mommy and she's always nice to me.
I don't know, she's just really kind and funny and she's mostly on my side in arguments so..
And she loves me a lot.
That's really all.
That's the most important part.
The last one and the most important part.
And this is probably a very bad drawing.